[Musique]
des musiciens qui ont passé par toute la
gamme des émotions
orchestre symphonique de Kiev bouleversé
par la guerre est venu faire vibrer les
dirigeants des pays membres de l'OTAN
une mélodie pour toucher les cœurs une
ouverture sur la culture qu'il tente de
protéger
plutôt dans la journée le Canada et ses
alliés ont promis de soutenir davantage
l'Ukraine
en modernisant l'équipement ukrainien
dit-il et en augmentant la force de
dissuasion de l'OTAN les États-Unis
annoncent donc une augmentation
significative de leur présence en Europe
permanent de l'armée américaine en
Pologne des avions de chasse stationnés
en Grande-Bretagne des systèmes
anti-aériens en Allemagne et en Italie
le Canada quant à lui apporte une
contribution plus modeste d'abord sur le
plan diplomatique nous allons ouvrir
quatre nouvelles ambassades puis sur le
plan militaire aujourd'hui nous signons
un partenariat avec le gouvernement de
la Lettonie le nombre de soldats de
l'OTAN en Lettonie va augmenter et c'est
l'armée canadienne qui sera responsable
de commander cette nouvelle brigade et
nous augmentons
considérablement nos contributions de
leur temps en Lettonie
s'effondre dit-il la prochaine guerre
sera chez nous
était capable de préciser combien de
soldats supplémentaires seront déployés
en Lettonie et le Canada ne réussit pas
à répondre à toutes les demandes et
exigences de l'OTAN ce que les Forces
armées canadiennes peuvent offrir aussi
c'est un rôle de leadership les attentes
envers le Canada sont grandes le temps
fait à nouveau pression pour une
augmentation des dépenses militaires
mais le niveau de 2% du PIB que le
Canada n'a jamais atteint et maintenant
considéré comme étant le strict minimum
les engagements d'aujourd'hui sont loin
d'atteindre la cible ici Christian Noël
Radio-Canada Madrid